okay for people who are joining this
live stream this is one of our
infinite series of language completeness
and consistency meetings for often
language
um i guess it's too late for version 12
2 right now
hopefully so this will be for future
versions
all right let's start off with should it
really be catch-off matrix
so everybody seems to call this a graph
laplacian
can we comment on this please where did
the term ketchup matrix come from
i mean it's depend of you know the
background culture of matrix
i mean at the time we have this pretty
much four names laplacian matrix
graph laplacian keyshot matrix and
admittance matrix
right so we wanted to call it matrix
something matrix because it's returning
matrix
not just a couple right and and
i mean the point i sort of made is that
you know you might think of the graph
laplacian
as the right as the scalar you get
when you apply that matrix to your
it's actually the discrete operator on
the laplacian
in the not very definitive um
wikipedia uh
referred to as the laplacian matrix
yes but in fact it uses laplacian
throughout the page
in fact we don't even see the word
kerchoff yes we do it's right in the
first sentence
yeah but that's not what most people use
it for i mean this is
the the right i mean
the other proposed name now we can have
is graph laplacian matrix i mean that's
the closest i come
i can see which feature right
because most of these other things are
you know
in this family that we have our foo
matrix so
yeah i mean i think graph laplacian
matrix i i have no deep objection to
graph laplacian matrix
i guess uh if if charles is okay with it
well i mean what what
i mean this is an existing function what
is kirchhoff graph
let's say it gives you the corresponding
half from the q sub matrix
so what would be a a graph laplacian
graph
up just laplacian half
which is coming from that matrix or the
corresponding operator
well but if it was called graph
laplacian matrix then you might want to
call it
graphoplasty and graph which is kind of
goofy
because the laplacian graph what on
earth is our laplacian graph
what what is this anyway
you mean the kickoff matrix
what does it really do i mean so
essentially it controls
the corresponding graph from the kickoff
matrix no no i
understand that but i mean why is that
is that a general thing to do
um yes the same has you have you know
adjacency graph adjacency matrix
weighted graph weighted matrix so
depending of
what type of operation doesn't even say
it's the graph laplacian here
right you probably need to add more see
also and all this stuff
also have anything of information here
doesn't have anything here
well of course that that background and
kind of stuff wasn't written by the team
right i mean that's that that's eric's
well in turn
who right we are working up updating
those those functions and documentation
these are
version 10 about seven or eight years
ago
version 8 actually ten years ago
okay so let me understand what other
i mean if if we have this
wait a minute what is this doing sorry
i'm i'm
confused here oops
okay so this has no options so don't
graph laplacians have the ability to
have
can't you isn't there a notion of an
arbitrary laplacian operator
well why there is a does it discrete i
mean the corresponding
case in this case is the scalar
partition of pareto yes
right so in principle graph laplacian
matrix
could take the laplacian operator that
it's going to use as well
justifying its life for the second name
yeah i guess so so let's just understand
how that graph laplacian operator would
be specified
that's interesting so there's different
normalizations for this
okay so does anybody know how we how we
can how we specify this
i don't know what these things are okay
so we need to look this up but i think
we're agreeing then
that there's the potential to have a
graph laplacian matrix
and a
laplacian matrix graph
although i'm not well i think the format
for all these functions like for example
adjacency matrix and adjacency graph and
kirchhoff matrix and kirkhof graph it's
it's
its name matrix and name graph
well so that means this would have to be
laplacian matrix
is there really nothing else called
euclasian matrix
laplacian matrix is too general i mean
there are several areas where
you know there is such a thing as like
pressure matrix really
according to wikipedia there's only one
i mean i i'd be shocked if there isn't
something else i mean
certainly i mean certainly in
you know in quantum field theory you
could might talk about the
the infinite dimensional graph laplacian
uh graphic the infinite uh dimensional
laplacian
operator right i mean which is
a a laplacian matrix i mean the problem
is that every
search on the web says this thing is
called laplacian matrix
okay not
kirchhoff matrix well they usually see
laplacian meters of
a graph right
actually that's not what i'm finding
anywhere here
i'm just finding it called laplacian
matrix
i think we just got the name wrong
i mean do you propose deprecating the
old one no i i
i think yes yes basically
every time i've used it it's just
annoying because i think the name is
wrong
that's so just la question matrix that's
what i think
[Music]
i mean unless somebody can give me good
evidence otherwise i everything i'm
finding says the laplacian matrix
is what we're talking about here and the
kirchhoff matrix is a rarely used name
and by the way it's
spelled wrong here
what spelled wrong that it's got two h's
unless i'm mistaken no that's right
actually on wikipedia i think it does
have two h's
all right i know this has two h's and
and our our
our version this is just a misspeller
okay yeah yeah okay
all right so look i think we should go
with laplacian matrix i think it's a
useful concept and i think we should
also understand how to give it
generalization
for a a discrete laplacian operator
that isn't just the most trivial you
know
um one in the middle of minus on the on
the edges
type thing okay what happens
just fyi um
laplacian matrix give gets six million
results on google and kirchhoff matrix
gets four million
so you know maybe kirchhoff matrix isn't
the most
uh you know the most dominant name but
it's not like it's a ridiculously wrong
name
okay fine let's have a generalized
laplacian matrix then
that has a you know a laplacian operator
that you can give a discrete laplacian
operator
which is essentially you know which is
basically the
what it should be is the is the
weighting of the graph neighborhood
does that make sense there's also the
normalization of the matrix but the most
obvious thing
is given the graph neighborhood right we
you're going out a certain number of
levels in the graft neighborhood
you're asking what is the sequence of
weightings as you go out in the graph
neighborhood
something sense charles yes
i would suggest we we think about that
right
right does the current because sometimes
people do this in terms of
right putting weights on the on the
vertices themselves does the kirchhoff
matrix
our current kirchhoff matrix look at any
properties like that or is it just doing
the the evenly weighted
guy so the currently cross matrix is
just
purely based on the adjacency matrix not
on the way to touch assisting matrix
okay there is there is more
consequential issue about the fact of
adding weight
so more technical issue related to that
right i mean i think there are look
there are two things one is the
laplacian operator itself
and the other is how you ingest weights
from the graph
right i think we both of those things
need to be looked at but bottom line is
we need an excuse to get
it called laplacian matrix
all right let's move on
check fail right so this is we were
cleaning out two
old tickets and you know this was a part
of one ticket
it's like check only instead of paying
attention to
uh messages that return yeah look i mean
the thing that i keep on finding myself
doing
is using enclose confirm
blah blah blah in other words what i
want to do
is this is basically saying if
it's basically a failure queue
not exactly failure to you i mean it's
like if it's some error
error if it represents some type of
error then wrapping the failure object
right so what is the thing that confirm
i mean if confirmed cue
this is the way to hold on though that
there are two things so we actually had
an email thread about this
like like a week ago i think it's
unrelated to this agenda item but it's
very
similar and that is that there's oh no
me me and me and yeah yeah i made it oh
although it's a part
private yeah it's completely unrelated
um which is why it's amusing but so the
thing is i think that there
there are maybe two different bits of
functionality which maybe can be made
into one function
so one of them is is this i don't think
confirmed q is necessarily the right
name but like some sort of like
error cue or something like that that
just tells you whether or not
you know can basically use the same
criteria that confirm has for checking
whether something
is some sort of obvious error the other
the other thing
um which sort of relates
to ways that some other languages deal
with errors like this sort of more
monad handling of errors would be to
have a function
that's basically a control flow thing
where you say
you know i don't know what to call this
function but like uh you know
foo it's like foo of and then you give
it an object
and then you give um you know a second
argument
which is basically a function that you
will apply to the object
if the object is not an error and then
there's an optional third argument which
is
a function that you apply if it is an
error
if that makes sense right so you say foo
of of
x x x um comma like
f and what that does is that if x xxx
is some horrible you know missing failed
whatever thing
it'll wrap in a failure object and if
it's not then it will apply
f to it and then there's another three
argument form
where you give sort of a handler that's
something other than rapid and a failure
object
okay so hold on so yeah that i think
that went a bit too fast for me to
well i think i understand what you're
saying but i think the argument order is
weird
i mean to me it's more of a headdress
story
i mean this is something like um
um okay a headdress might be a good way
to do it
right so so for example let's say
confirm apply
f and then um
we'll first do the one argument version
don't don't do the fail
right so so what you can do
does does is it says confirm applied of
f of x
if it either gives if f of x is going to
be a happy creature
right then i don't know if x is a happy
creature x is a happy creature
oh okay all right okay if x is happy
then the result is f of x if x is
unhappy
then the result is failure of whatever
yes
so it just propagates the error up yeah
sorry right
well i i have to say this sounds weird
to me that we're using
confirm for something that isn't going
to be wrapped in
in an enclosed i agree i don't think i
want to find
the word okay but i mean in
um but but hold on
let's just understand this object so
what this is saying is
okay right so this is a generalized
version of of the check fail
right so the check the original check
fail proposal just to make sure we're
all
agreed on what that is is basically if
failure queue
right the original check fail is
basically replace
uh you know check fail of x
comma y is
replace of x uh you know
failure q goes to you know f
right wait a minute
check fail of what check fail of
x comma y is
x replace is is replace
well replace x x and blank
uh question mark failure yeah okay
you know goes to y
right it's x if x is not failure q and
if it is failure q
it returns y which
i mean so the question is the packaging
are you doing this when you apply a
function or are you doing this
in other words i mean this confirm
applied thing
could be done in this check fail way
by just saying check fail of f of x
comma y right now now the only thing is
though
so so this check fail thing is actually
first of all i think you want a rule
rule delayed because you don't want to
evaluate the y unless
it is failure q the other thing is that
um
i think this is basically the same this
is basically the same thing as the
original version
the non-check confirm applied the one
that i just called foo
um but uh yeah this is a this is an
expression
function wrapper right but i think that
the function wrapper is
probably more relevant because i think
the most common case
is i have this thing and i want to do
stuff with it
but if it's junk i just want to
propagate the error up
instead of doing stuff to it well which
i think i think i think well
right but i think that's the opposite of
what of the purpose of check fail
check fail is if what i have is junk
replace it with a default value that i
will use
right which oh i see okay yeah which you
know like
it's a legitimate request i'm just not
sure it's worth packaging up especially
since we've
since we've decided check is stupid and
we've
and we've now written confirm and close
to replace it i'm not sure
yeah it's it's basically a version of
that right
well i don't know if check is i mean
check is silly for other reasons
like check is silly because it doesn't
stop immediately but i think the design
of check isn't necessarily
right like yeah but the thing we're
trying to do
is we're trying to have a function which
if it's first argument is junk
it's basically if look his here's the
function it's if
failure if error q whatever that means
if error q of hash if not error q of
hash
hash otherwise
otherwise fail
it's some sort of default value thing
it's like
replace this with a default value if
it's if it doesn't have a value itself
right
so basically you turned my replace
expression into an if statement
but it's exactly the same thing
right okay so so
what this is doing is if you've got
junk this is a wrapper which is saying
if you get
junk turn it into this and one could
imagine a um
uh an operator form of it that says
um you know yes this is easy
replace fail of expo
yep um
this reminds me very much of of the
option failure action
of query which is something specifying
what to do in the case of an
of an error sorry say that again jose
uh yes can we have a look at the page of
failure action
so it's um it's an option of query that
specifies what to do
in the case of uh of a failure
and and there are the the details is
probably the most important thing to
look at
this is for data set right yeah
well end query
hmm
well that's interesting
anybody ever used this
well it has a default value i think its
default value is abort
which ends up influencing a lot of
things
but um i think i've rarely ever
changed other than maybe to none
okay but what this is doing
okay so this is within query
this is like a confirm within query type
thing
right well if you set it to abort it's
kind of like a confirm inside query
but if you set it to you know replace or
or
encapsulate then not necessarily it's
more like this thing we're talking about
now
so
i mean there's a very trivial
okay maybe i'm being stupid about this
but but let's say
um um
let's say we have something like this
check applied
[Music]
no
um hold on a second well this isn't
quite the right rate round but but
something like this where basically
what's happening is that function f
is applied to exper
and if the function f applied to exper
wait a minute they're two different
things right we want i i think you're
better off
checking if exper has problems than you
are checking at f
express problems right yeah that's why i
like the junk replace of fail of exper
right right okay fine and then that then
one could imagine a thing that is a
a full version of this which is junk
replace
of i mean maybe even an operator form
but but i mean junk replacer fail
and then um
failed test expo
wait that's not the argument order is it
well i don't know
okay should probably be expert fail
failed test
possibly yes i thought i thought only
the operator form had failed first
but i guess okay so i guess we have like
three different
concepts running around here and maybe
we should figure out what subset
makes sense right so there's the the
first one is just the error q
which seems like that's probably makes
sense to have
right so so is i i'm sorry but is is
i my understanding of what confirm was
doing is that it was basically using
failure queue is that understanding
wrong it uses a few it uses uh failure
queue or missing queue
or if it's dollar cancelled and i think
that's it
so it does a couple of things okay
but i i think it would be nicer if there
was just some function that's like the
is this some obvious kind of missing
value
you know there isn't a value here it's
some error
i i just don't like calling it an error
because it's not obvious that missing is
an
error
troubled cue
well i mean what about admitting it's
it's um uh it's relationship to confirm
i i just think that confirm like the
word confirm only means something
because you know the function confirm
like if you don't know the function
confirm then using confirm this context
i think is kind of meaningless
okay what are some other things other
than trouble
which i don't think is but there's got
to be some other junk
right and it's actually the negation of
that right that we're trying to
get right right do we want deposit oh we
want to right the question is do we want
to junk queue or not
junk queue well hold on q because it
should be like failure q and missing q
right okay it's a generalization of
failure missing
okay so then to assume we have a junk
queue
then this is going to do junk repli then
then there's a junk replaced
type thing well but again there are two
versions right
and i don't know if it you know it makes
sense to have both or what
so one version is basically the you know
for people who like haskell it's the
equivalent of
of like f map over a maybe so it's
basically it's like
it's like i want to apply function to
this
if it's sensible and otherwise i want to
just propagate the senseless thing so
it's like a monad
map kind of thing um
and and for that you're right right and
that's that's the inverse of this check
fail
junk junk replace thing but the
difference is and the reason why it's
slightly complicated is i think that
that one this sort of monad apply one
you want to give it a function
that it's going to apply versus the junk
replace where i
think you probably just want to give it
an expression
yeah i mean you could give it a function
you could give it a function for example
if you wanted to have it do something
like
wrap the x in a failure object then
you'd want to give it a function but
i think much more often you don't want
that
yeah i mean this is a nice thing to be
able to insert into a piece of code
you've got you've got something where
this would be a nice thing to put in the
code i mean not this name
but in other words because i really like
the pattern that i use all the time
where you just insert an echo
and you don't the code keeps on working
the pipeline keeps working but it just
does something
so in this case it's like the pipeline
is working but the code is doing
something crazy
and oh in that weird in that case of
failure
you know do this type thing yeah now one
other question is
you know because we also talked about
having a failed test um
should it also have like a level spec
because this sort of seems like it's a
bit like delete missing
or something like that
which of course has a level spec yeah
well in fact
missing even has a kind of sophisticated
level spec which this could have
i mean so at some level i think this is
kind of similar so delete missing is
you know really missing of course only
is for missing not for this generalized
example but delete missing is basically
any data that's not
perfect and pure get rid of it right
so this is any data that's not perfect
and pure replace it
if missing occurs within the first d
levels of the element
right so this is why the symbolic we're
delete missing as more complicated
behavior because
you can delete things that contain
missings
no i understand i understand this says
gosh i've been doing all this stuff with
combinators recently
and what i finally understood i finally
finally understood by thinking about
causal graphs of combinators
is this long-running issue of there are
two ways that you can recurse
in evaluation one is by reevaluating
something you already evaluated
and the other is by continuing recursion
through an expression
and those two things by the way
i i will soon have a proposal for a very
beautiful
traversal order set of traversal order
options for map and so on
for what it's worth for those who've
been waiting for traversal order options
for 30 years
why is there no enthusiasm for this very
good okay well
i'm sorry traversal order for map you
said
well and ultimately traversal order for
evaluation
but but but initially it's traversal
order for map because map
right now if if i do a map look if i say
if i take a random it's a step first
you're saying you you have some
alternative to depth first
yeah exactly if i if i have a random
thing like this
um and i say
map echo map all
metal
echo onto that okay yeah i do better i
have
i believe i mean not nearly this
complicated but i do believe i have a
documentation example
effectively doing that to illustrate how
different level specs are treated in the
documentation
i actually vaguely remember that example
okay right
okay so the point here is there are many
i mean we've now got code that does all
the different
you know well there are many what what
you're doing there
is you can imagine this if i do a map
if i say map indexed onto
um map indexed of echo
2 right onto percent 903
uh at level you know level zero to
infinity
i wonder whether we should have all
there is all should be supported there
really i didn't know that is that right
wow i did not know that is that
everywhere that takes level specs
should be pretty much all of them does
it does it set heads to true
um it does not it's just a value for the
level spec
it does not change okay this traversal
order
right illustrates a um actually i should
use this something i'm writing about
this but
but um this traversal order illustrates
you know but you know you can think of
these as being sorted this is
uh left most innermost i believe
sure wrong yeah um
depth first word always goes left yeah
depth first
which is right where it where it is left
to right scanning
without heads and it
is so there are many other forms like
like
uh left most outermost which is
kind of like uh you know
where where you're sorting where you're
doing the held function
application rather than the arguments
first and then the function
and you can do things like outermost
leftmost and things like this
but in general there's a sorting
function on these parts
that determines what the traversal order
is yep
and so the issue i mean okay for this
case the reason it's tricky
is this is static traversal order okay
the next thing you can ask is if you're
doing recursive evaluation
and one of these things could be
re-evaluated
in what order do you do re-evaluation as
compared to part traversal
so so for example do you continue doing
re-evaluation to drill drill drill drill
drill to get to a fixed point for that
thing
or do you keep traversing the expression
and look for other things
to um to drill on
yep right i guess i guess part of the
reason
that i i perhaps am not as excited as
you is because i very much use map and
such things
in ways where i want to do exactly one
evaluation at each step so the fact
that the traversal order doesn't for the
most part doesn't matter that way
assuming that it's a confluent rewriting
system it doesn't make any difference
but the fact is i mean this traversal
order thing
is the most relevant case of traversal
order
is actually for partial functions where
things don't terminate
because then it really matters um but
there are also cases i mean look
honestly i tried a whole giant
experiment within that
this an smp that was a disaster because
nobody understood it
and you know this is a coming back 40
years later to try and see if we can
actually get this right
um okay anyway that's traversal order
but but this is
what we're what we're talking about here
is something went wrong
what you've got is garbage see i can
imagine
things like if it didn't evaluate if
it's just generally garbage
you know more like a confirmed type
thing where
this is how can it know i don't know how
no something like that well i understand
it's the same same as you would confirm
right i mean
confirm test you go ahead another way of
thinking about it though
is is which i i think is more natural is
that it's like a default value
i see as opposed to something went wrong
it's just like there is no value what's
the default
yes there's no meaningful value what is
the default value question the value
queue
maybe that's overly intellectual but it
that's
really that's really weird um question
question questionable yeah
okay um
unresolved value queue unresolved wait a
minute
we don't want to q there's one thing is
the queue and the other is
we want something which is there are
three things
three oh yeah there's your monarch thing
as well there's the monad thing if we're
for buying that but well hold on let me
let me understand the modern thing again
so so we've got first question is
we've got questionable value queue of
expert true or false
okay then we've got um
look i think we want to name the the
yeah we need to name junk right
if we can name junk we've got junk cube
but then what does this one get called
the junk group the one that's currently
called junk replace
or the monad one no the junk replaced
one
i think something like replace junk or
junk replace is probably
worse i i think replace junk is better
just because
yeah junk replay sounds like it's
something in the replace family which
this isn't i mean it sort of is but it's
it right it's not taking a rule it's
taking a default value
so right it's like missing or something
like that
right yeah i agree okay replace junk
fail
okay and then the argument order of this
would be
in the case where it would be replace
junk
x become a fail
right now again unless we want this to
be a pure headdress form
in which case we could add optional
second arguments there which wouldn't be
bad
because yeah i mean i think a pure head
i mean
right so i think again there's there's
there's the pure headdress form would be
nice
there's there's this form and then
there's also i mean again no
you can see it there's something where
it's like you'd have a headdress it's a
very simple function or you can see it
is basically in the delete missing
family
where you're applying it to data in
addition to just like individual things
right and then you need those level
specs
i don't think clean queue is terrible
except it's the opposite way around from
junk
right unclean q
that sounds really good let's not do
that
um
heretical cue
well it's interesting that clean cue you
know we just started with cleanup i mean
we're now going clean
so to speak right
it is fairly i mean if you saw that in a
piece of code it's not completely stupid
but what would it be what would be what
would be this one then
[Music]
uh
wait which which would not be completely
stupid clean cue
okay okay so the monad one has a much
more natural name than the
replace junk one what is the mod name
well i mean the point is just that i
think it would have clean in its name
like like you would have something like
you know clean apply
or uh i don't know okay so let's
let me review again what this one does
so clean apply
would be um
what what does it do now clean up so if
x
so okay um again i don't i guess it
should probably be a headdress
so clean apply of f of x if
x is is unclean
then it will wrap it in a failure object
and and return that
and if x is clean it will return f of x
one way of thinking about this
is it's it's identical to
enclose except or it's identical to
confirm
except confirm when it detects an error
it can propagate the error up an
arbitrary distance
to the enclosed as opposed to this which
propagates the error up one level
okay so if x is not clean q return
essentially failure of x right
there's actually another way one way of
thinking about this it's exactly the
same
basically exactly the same as enclose of
f
of confirm of x
close of f of confirm
of x yes i understand that
so i don't understand why this isn't
confirmed applied or something confirm
apply
confirmed applied well it's because you
don't like having a
a naked confirm without its enclosing
and close
exactly yeah
i was actually thinking the other day
though this is a different discussion
and i think maybe this is a bad idea to
introduce something like this
but you could always have something
where a naked confirm basically
makes like an abort that just goes like
to the top level in some way by
i don't like what is it doing right now
what does it do right now
so right now it okay so right now
an untagged confirm just without an
enclosed
throws a message and returns null um but
if you give a tagged enclosed that
doesn't have or a tag to confirm sorry
that doesn't have a matching enclose
right then it gives a message
analogous to the uncut throw message and
it returns the failure object at the top
level
i don't see how you can justify not
returning to the top level
an unenclosed confirm
yeah well i mean that that's why so i
thought about you know
i thought about what for the for the the
confirm with no matching tag
right i thought about like maybe i
should do like what throw does and
return some hold of
confirm of whatever or just return some
kind of nonsense thing or just null
and i thought i mean i have no
justification for not returning the
failure object to the top level
okay so hold on i think one of the
things that we have not yet addressed
is what is the top level and what is the
safety net around the top level
right this is why i don't like things
that return to the top level
wow top level is a very undefined thing
because top level you know in the cloud
top level in a different
evaluation environment is something kind
of weird what what is the right
definition i mean
in other words there is basically
you know the outermost shell of what's
going on
there is you return to the outermost
shell i mean at some point quit
returns beyond the outermost shell it
breaks out
you know it returns the operating system
eventually you could have a you know
restart my computer function
that um uh the question i really hope we
don't
well it's not relevant for look it would
be relevant if you know
for a raspberry pi doing iot stuff it's
not completely a silly thing to do
and what if you mean sudo to do that but
yes okay
well it depends how you set your device
up it depends i wonder what
on like a spacecraft i wonder whether
that how the sudo
business works okay
anyway in any um
the the uh but my point is
what does it mean when you know when it
reaches the top level
what is the catching framework like and
how is that defined in other words
it could very well be the case that what
we haven't done is we've got things like
pre
and post which are like 30 years old
which are occasionally used although
they're very dangerous to use
the top level is by definition very
global
and the question is in a sense in close
is defining a pseudo top level
so the question is what is the effective
and close what is the
enclose of the world so to speak what is
the shelling enclosed
that defines the top level okay
encloses one i mean just any scoping
construct is defining quotes at the top
level i mean catch does two
or you know some of those weird stack
functions do
two and so on but fair enough but then
what is the parameterization i mean the
problem is
the notion of sorry are you asking how
it works right now or are you asking
how should it work and i mean i'm asking
within a dialogue is that top level is
that not top level i don't know right
i mean i i think it's some level you
know the unusual response is probably
just that like
when the the level like the console that
the human is operating on
right but of course there isn't always a
human and yeah the human maybe
you have no sure right
um right well i i think a dial i mean if
you mean a dialogue as in dialogue
bracket bracket right that absolutely
does define
a top level right it does it does
do a sort of yeah it does a main loop
thingy yeah uh it assigns to ins and
outs etc
i think actually system dialogue is one
of the only there's a special case for
it in
top eval so yes
system dialogue or dial i think it's
called
i think it's called system well i think
it's like if you throw certain kinds of
aborts
um then yeah it has
special i think it might be when you
like close the dialogue or something
like that
or submit the dialogue okay so there are
two points here one is an unenclosed
confirm what should it do
and i do believe unless i'm
i mean completely confused it seems to
make
me to make sense for it to return to top
level the second point is i claim at
some point in the in the future
we need to get more precise about what
we mean by top level and what services
basically are being caught
you know what is the catch all for the
top level
i mean it catches almost everything but
it doesn't catch a quit for example
there is actually a function called
catch everything which is exactly the
function that does this
internally it's not top level function
but
yeah i mean well it won't
it won't catch a quit yeah you know i
know this function happens to be called
that so it's sort of appropriate yes
right the basic question is when when
does top okay the
the with the actual question is
basically when does the function
called top eval get called that's
basically
the question yeah or when should it get
called
and how much control should internal
code have over that because you can
really mess things up by
affecting the you know the top-level
rebel but i think okay that's not
relevant to what we're doing here so
let's go back into this um
um
okay purkinje on our livestream says
it's important to encapsulate the error
so you can use it like a monitor to make
it participate in categories of
combinators
yes that that's the idea of these
failure wrappers
and that's exactly what confirm is doing
is it's wrapping it
so that it can be used in other places
well it's one of the things it does but
i think it would be good to have a more
pure function
that's what we're kind of talking about
now be good to have a more pure function
that just does that
right okay so then then what you're
saying here
okay if f is not clean q return failure
of x
which then so if if in a sense what you
could do is you could say
clean apply of f of clean apply
of g of x and that's equivalent
to you know enclosing confirm right
that could be enclosed of f
of confirm no
f of continue
no it's different from that because f
and g could individually fail so i think
it's enclosed
of f oh yes isn't it confirmed
in close of in note in close of f
of confirm of g of confirm of x
the first confirms inside the f why
isn't there a confirm outside the f as
well
because i mean
because there just isn't i mean like
like because it's checking the input to
the f it's checking if the
if the input to the f is clean what
about if the output to the f
is well if it's some failure thing then
then
presumably you'll have something outside
of it to deal with the thing i see i see
okay fair enough fair enough fair point
okay so then then the issue here is this
is simply checking
that whether the thing that f is fed
okay so we've been thinking about this
combinator like with just
you know one argument things but what
about the case where you've got
f g you know f of x y z
and one of them so in other words in
that case if we say clean apply
of f of x y z
there's a question of what that does and
then even
even worse there's the issue of
attributes like if f is hold
all then you can't really do this
um well and there's a worse case
um
there's things like that i mean i i
guess
yes uh i've just been living in
combinator land too long
yeah i'm less worried about that than
attributes
what what does the attributes thing the
attributes thing is that you can't
check these things if f has attributes
whole
has hold attributes then clean apply of
f does
what does it just can't use it because
it's going to run all those
it's going to run x y and z you can't
have attributes on some values
although we should probably fix that at
some point that's another topic
it's a well it was an agenda item for
today but tom couldn't make it and there
was no point in having
the conversation without tom so fine
by the way here's an amusing fact for
you so the whole notion of up value is
only going a fixed distance
is deeply reminiscent of how the s
combinator works
just for what it's worth just to give it
some history what's that
it's a very this is a very themed
meeting it's a very themed meeting
but you know the fact that in in
whatever it is 35 years i've never
noticed that connection
and is is kind of telling um
um i'd like to take a break from this
direction and just looking at sort of
antonyms of of clean
there's uh tainted obviously there's
unclean but i'm not sure that sounds
good but maybe
tainted no yeah
[Music]
does it deal with hold
attributes okay but let's just make sure
we understand what we're naming
so one thing is
this apply that is going to propagate
where this if this isn't
clean then
it propagates that so it only applies
f in a sense in a sense the meaning is
quotes only apply f
if its arguments are clean
yeah right and i guess what does it
return if
if the arguments are not clean will it
just be earlier
of just the fir the first argument that
isn't clean or
whatever i yeah that is a good question
i mean i remember
so back before even the ideas for
enclosing confirm were like fully formed
this was one of the ideas and one of the
issues was exactly this
of if you have multiple arguments what
do you do
um so i mean i think
like yeah yeah i mean
you could always make it so it only
takes one argument i think that's a
little restrictive
i mean i think just the first one
why not just give it look look it's
going to be a failure object so why not
put in the failure object in the
association for the failure object
you know failed arguments
arrow whatever it is unfailed arguments
are whatever it is or something
or maybe i mean whatever the most useful
form of that is but you can put in the
association you can
you can have the description of all
those different things
i think that's the right way to do that
but okay this this comes back to the
question of what
okay so one thing is
you've got the thing you want to simply
replace it
this is a case where
you're applying the function
okay what is that what is our family of
names here
so first question is
so by the way just to be clear about
because it seems like you're sort of
acting like these are similar
things i mean like the the replace junk
one
is like a recovery situation where it's
like
something went wrong but i'm going to
fix it and we're going to continue
the other one is is a you know it's a
failure propagation thing it's like if
something went wrong
and you know i'm going to stop now i'm
just rather than
stopping completely i'm just going to
report an error and trust that
the next guy in the chain knows how to
recover for me
exactly yeah right propagate an error
this is replaced with a default
and the thing above it is the test that
we will use is nothing wrong
yep wrong queue clearly i was thinking
about wrong
the only thing about wrong queue is it
sort of implies like you're going to
type something in like two plus two
equals five and it's going to return
true because it's wrong
right yeah okay what are some synonyms
there i mean wrong q
is better than um or okay
q the problem with okay q is that
okay will be upper k i mean you could do
okay a y
q oh that's a ridiculous naming thing
look
okay that's just too informal we're not
going that informal yet
wait for another 10 years 20 years or
something
there um
muddy hazy yeah
right i was going to suggest sloppy q as
as opposed to clean
bad q but that's not good either
rotten queue
here's another place where we could
introduce fuzzy into the names oh
i i i i this is this i i suggested all
serious
polluted q
no i mean because that's going to be
like it has
you know 10 parts per million of lead in
it
okay fine but but but
well i mean we could do like tainted cue
i mean that's certainly certainly in cs
right in in cs circles that's entirely
comprehensible i don't know if
it's not and that's hopeless otherwise
tainted is it's just too
weird it's too too many other things
okay um
invalid improper
these are judgment calls i guess they're
i mean in proper
improper sounds i i still think that
maybe error q is not that bad i mean i
get that like for example
missing it's a little weird and maybe
it's also a little weird
because it's unclear what the difference
between failure queue is
yeah well but all of these have the
issue of
it's unclear what the difference between
them and failure q is
i mean arguably well
maybe this is wrong but arguably in the
past
failure q should have just detected
things like missings and dollar cancels
and stuff like that
because i think that would have been the
right name
maybe expected unexpected
well um okay what are some other terms
mistake mistaken
it's not very good it's not a mistake
that you know
one over zero is no i mean yeah
well what isn't it it's not something
that you can go on with
it's not something that you can take
further it's not a value
it's not a meaningful it's not a useful
value
it's like an error value or something
useless
q
um the opposite of robust
i mean we could go with like
possible error q sort of like possible
zero q
yeah we can do better i mean
i'm wondering whether we want to just
extend
missing with you know so like
either a second argument or
just like missing q with a second
argument that
allows other things and then
or why not failure queue then right or i
mean
my concern is that we have a whole
family of functions around missing and a
whole family functions around
failure and whatever and we need a
generic term
that encompasses both of those
right or or we generally you know pick
one of them and generalize it
i mean this is what i was saying you
know in the past it would have been nice
if mate
it might have been nice if for example
failure q did this
because there is a bit of the risk of
the you know what is the xkcd where it's
like you just introduce another standard
and then they're
they're now 16 competing standards right
right
the new you maybe the new universal
standard
right how about erroneous queue
what about unreliable queue because
right that's really the
so we've had a number of suggestions on
the live stream exception cue
i'm no yeah i mean i understand where
that's coming from but i think
that's too easy to confuse with you know
actual like exceptions right it sounds
like it's going to stop evaluation
yeah um i like from
hans here does it flow q that would be
nice
except it's too informal uh mal formed q
barbie q what the hell oh bobby
honey uh okay corrupted kill formed q
garbage queue
um malformed q is
not or or how about unusable cue
have we done unexpected yes i think
unexpected is too
it's in the eye of the beholder
clearly you expected it a little bit
because you asked whether or not it was
unexpected
it's nobody expects the spanish in
position
well we can have that right
that case um this is
okay no no no no okay i
was gonna say that spanish inquisition
you know should basically be plus one so
you give it a number and it does
one more on top of that
wow or you give it a list and it gives
you length plus one right
[Music]
uh why is it taking so long uh blight
obedience to the pope
queue uh probably too long okay all
right
let's let's i'm surprised not i'm
surprised that isn't that's very
interesting that we don't
it's a it's one of those little data
curation issues i mean that's not
that doesn't make it like if we say
um what was the war that the spanish
armada was part of
april you mean lord nelson
you mean 1588 right what was the name of
that war
was was it not a war was it just a
step uh i think the battle of trafalgar
or something
no that that trafalgar was a century
later with
nelson um uh
jose is quiet
[Laughter]
steven is referring to what was it was
it the was it the
30 years war spanish armada
it what's a hapsburg uh i'm
this is terrible what what um um and we
don't
i mean there's the famous armada when
philip ii tried to invade england
right the one we're talking about what
is it called
what is it called in spain is it called
the expedition was the largest
engagement of the undeclared
anglo-spanish war of 1585-1604
so that's why it doesn't have a name
because it wasn't
actually a war or at least it wasn't the
declared war
there we go anglo-spanish war what do
you know
the i have a feeling we've gotten
slightly off-track
and there's spanish armada oh there were
multiple ones there's like the third
spanish armada there okay i'm sorry
we are off track here
cause that never happens this means
well we didn't expect it so
wow look at that what's that is that
that's not the azores is it is that the
azores
i mean it's the canary islands no the
thing is
um okay let's go back here
let me try meaningful cue oh yeah
we have a meaningful cue though um
off topic queue legitimate queue
that's an interesting one from bob
none of these are quite right we're
circling here there is a good name for
this um
no way undeclared no we don't
um look what is the basic point of it
the basic point is
really can you expect it to go on being
computed from
right well
no because well no because there are
functions that
that happily take errors and failure
cues and process them
i mean i think i think it's does this
thing have a value
or is it just an error
okay i.e does it have
does it have a value that an
ordinary function can take as an
argument
and that's really it's um i mean really
it is
you know it's not failure q really is
the thing because i mean you can even
say like if something is missing or
something like that it means that
there is a failure in getting the value
whether it's because it doesn't make
sense or because it's
i don't know i think failure q would
have been the right thing but it's too
late
is it too late
probably i mean failure queue i think
just does dollar failed
i think it just does actually both of
the dollar aborted
well if it does dollar aborted honestly
i mean
it could have some feature creep but but
if let's say that it was called failure
q let's say that that was what
the q version of this was called what
would the other things be called
then this would be called replace
failure
which is not a terrible name
perhaps well here here's another
question could there be a delete failure
which sort of supersedes delete missing
as the more general one
possibly yes and then there's separately
there's replace failure which is kind of
the
you know goes along with it okay so that
would be replace failure so then what
would this one be called what would the
propagate the error be i mean it could
be called propagate failure
in haskell it's called fmap which stands
for functor map
i'm guessing that's probably not a good
name is it even called what does it have
to do with functors
what does it have to do with functors
because because you
maybe is a monad and so or maybe he's a
functor
in haskell terms and so it's it's
mapping over functor in the sense of
category ethereal function in some other
sense
it is it is close to the category theory
sense but it's like slightly different
okay um
okay family work failure cue replace
failure
and this would be
what what is this really doing this is
saying
if
successor i mean if we wanted to sort of
mirror the
to clean apply name it could be success
supply
right because they're not it'd be nice
to be call it something applied
right because if it was successfully
applied
well the thing about success is success
is good because we do have success
objects which are kind of the opposite
of failures
but there is kind of a law of excluded
middle problem that we've got
right because not everything is a
success or a failure
right there
um okay let me think about this
so if it was going to be applied and it
was going to be
this is a something applied function
x applied function which if the thing
was
um what what is the definition here
is a i mean like reverse supplied for
example
is you know just to remem remember what
some applied
things do that's reverse supplied
and the curry applied which i'm afraid
it's about to get renamed based on my
historical research hasn't created
already been renamed like twice
or something at least once because it's
the term
i don't even know how to use it well
there's also the operator apply which
which is similar to curry applied but
not quite in some subtle way
oh operator pride is much more useful i
mean i i would say that
um right it
did it defaults it has a different
default
for for operation forms right yeah yeah
right
um okay so what is the applied what is
the form
to be applied here where
and some sense it's unsuccess applied
yes it's not a terrific name but it's
accurate right right right right apply
on success
basically apply on success applied
and we can talk about the positive like
what it does if it's a success or we can
talk about the negative of what it does
if it's a failure
but if we're going to use the applied
term it better be what it does
oh i see i see um
no failure applied
unfailed unfailing applied hardly
that just sounds wait
um i mean i i think there's a very
general thing here that we're trying to
name the specific case of
which is i mean it's very common that i
want to map a function across
and you know if it's this thing then do
one thing and otherwise just return the
original value
but it has nothing to do with let's just
say that again sorry i missed
that right i mean so it's like imagine
i'm processing
plot ranges or something and i'm
applying scaling functions
and and so i do a map and if
it's a number then i apply the scaling
function
and if it's automatic or all or whatever
then i leave it as is then you're using
the wrong function because you should be
replacing it level one
but uh
but this is a legitimate thing
i mean in the case where it's like a min
max
type scenario i guess that's true right
i mean
in general this will be at a point where
we've already expanded
the plot range out into the full you
know x-men x-max y-min y-max
sort of thing okay and so i think
there's like a test applied
or test apply sort of thing okay so this
is a different category this is
something like
test applied um where
what you're saying is if
okay so basically what that would be is
test applied
um and then there's a condition here
and then there's a um in the functions
no test applied right
there's two arguments to it one is what
the condition is and one is what
you're going to apply right so test
applied
of the of a function with a condition
and then what do you do otherwise then
then you do if if the condition isn't
satisfied then what you do
is you have basically then then there's
a failure case here
well you returned you returned the the
thing that was passed in
i think well the default is i mean this
is this is another
this is actually another interesting
possible behavior for the
whatever we're calling confirm applied
or the thing you were earlier calling
confirm applied
which which is that instead of wrapping
in a failure object it could just return
the x right because first of all you
know that the x is detectable as like by
failure cue or whatever
um and so it's sort of not it's not like
some sort of
subtle error that you don't want
floating around and that you want to
encapsulate something more obvious
um and and it would be it might be nice
if it just returns the thing
directly because it means you can do
nice stuff like there's a very common
case
which i think might even be in the
function repository which is like a
map missing where you map over something
and you basically want to do
if missing cue or you know more
generally if failure q of hash
then hash otherwise f of hash right
but the point is you want it to you know
you don't necessarily want to wrap the
failure
missing or whatever you just want to
propagate it as is okay so
test applied if that was a
that basically says so let's do a
bracket x after that
i did that that okay right
after the first one right right so what
that does
is if the condition is true right
if cond of x f
x else x right
so that thing if cond of x
f of x otherwise x or in more generality
if conduct x f of x otherwise
default function of x now i don't know
what the argument order whether the
argument
order is right i mean to me
the more convenient thing to do would be
to say
let's see yeah i see it's like curry
applied
where the function yeah so that that's
like curry applied apply it
only when this condition is true but i'm
not sure where the default function goes
i think it goes at the end and there's
identity
yeah it's usually identity
or could be failure
right well certainly what brett wants is
identity i know but i mean the
the case that we're discussing otherwise
is failure q failure
that's the other case right that's the
monad
that's the monad error propagation
function i believe
you mean if not failure q failure
right you're right
by the way you guys really want to be
horrified i mean i've been thinking
about
you know in combinators not to return to
combinators but you realize that they
get rid of
every variable name right you never need
variable names
unfortunately they are absolutely
incomprehensible and that's the only
feature of combinators in 100 years that
has not been caught on
is the you know fundamental non-use of
variable names
i mean lambda calculus uses variables
names etc etc
so i was pondering the question of given
that we live in a time
where for example one can even have code
that is more graphical where one can
have arrows from here to there and so on
and you know graphs mixed with code is
there any way to avoid variables that's
useful
just like this which i claim is our
pronoun
and we only have one of it and so for
example when you have nested levels of
pronouns
you don't know what refers to what
so you say you know the cat
would change the the mouse which ate the
cheese
and it was whatever
you don't know which layer of that that
thing
the it refers to and that's the same
issue we have with nested functions with
hash
why am i getting so little enthusiasm
for this issue
i well i didn't entirely follow
so the issue is if you have nested
look look your nesting functions right
you say f
of hash and you apply that
you know that's happily applied to x
right but now let's say we want
something else here where we have
another function that's going to be
applied to this
we have a g of hash here and we want to
and the question then is which
i'm getting myself confused but but when
we have two layers of nested functions
and they both use hash you know at some
point we have to start naming
you know x and so on right now the code
assistant system can offer renamings
like that
but the question is is there some way i
mean essentially what's happening is
this is the same issue as with pronouns
in english
it's what does it refer to what does the
it
refer to so to speak another analogy
here
is that variables for functions are like
indices for tensors so i think what you
are looking for is the equivalent of the
bird tracks
yes that's a good observation bird
tracks
okay i'm not familiar with that term in
the context of tensors it's tensor it's
it's
it's showing bird tracks show which
tensor index go goes with which other
tensor index
okay right i mean this is the the the um
that's an interesting
thought so you're suggesting is there a
way
i don't remember enough about um
uh let's see bird tracks bird tracks
bird tracks
um this is okay so here
here we've got i mean these are metric
tons all right
okay i was going to ask if this is the
graphical
the the little lines connecting your
your slots and
right so it's this type of thing what's
that
uh just i'm reminded of of
how different the these graphs of are of
how i imagine things
you mean could we use this for
the question is can we use this to
represent
you know because this is basically
saying this tensor index goes with this
other tensor index
because basically the hash is being fed
from something
right and so what we're seeing here is
that the hash is being fed from this
slot here
so in effect what we could be doing is
if we could draw an arrow
right if we took this can i do this
this is totally crazy can i can i put
this in as a canvas
uh yes canvas of that will
will create uh i don't think canvas of
an image works
i think i have to create that as a
background to the canvas
there we go okay so now here
wait a minute where are the tools you
need to click on it
why did it why did it go that that crazy
twiddling well well okay so then here
let's let's really use some technology
here where's freehand drawing
this why is that not is that a third
icon
the non-arrow zigzag i see
okay so now what this is saying is
ah why isn't this you want to select the
little loopy thing in the
top of the tab
draw a free hand line okay so this is
now going from there to there
yep so this is saying
and i could in principle say i also want
to go from there to
there well as as you have written it
that's exactly what you're doing
right that's as
but i'm saying that that
the issue would be could you indicate in
code
see here's an interesting point i mean
the code assistance system could
annotate
with these kinds of things that would be
interesting
see what i'm saying so in other words if
you want to know where did this argument
come from
right it could annotate by showing those
arrows
you know the lack of enthusiasm that
sounds like it would get
really complicated and confusing in
anything other than a trivial example
right i'm reminded a bit of the debugger
where
it would draw these nested rectangles
around
things which is fine if everything's on
one line
but as soon as you start having you know
a five
line expression or something
then your rectangles aren't rectangles
they're
they're these non-convex things
yes yes yes yes i just had this
experience
with my friend combinators again because
they also get very complicated and
multi-line and you're trying to indicate
what
what is the frame so to speak of of uh
well reacts and combinators um
i don't think this is totally stupid so
if we can if we can take this to the
code assistance uh sorry yeah to the
code assistance meeting that will be
useful
this this thing about annotating what's
already there as opposed to
the thing about actually writing code in
this form which i admit is probably
questionable right and to some extent
the head highlighting may already do
that in some cases
that's true that's true it does to some
extent it gives you an idea although i
find that very confusing
and i i don't know whether in 12-2 is
the
modern version of greening did that get
implemented does anybody know
i believe so
i mean i've always found greening
utterly confusing so there
i click there and that's the head i
click there that's the head
i click there and i don't see anything
because the head is not visible
um
what happens if you select the
exclamation point
nothing
what was the previous greeting i mean
this screening appears to be quite
reasonable
i have to admit i've never really
understood the greening that we had
we had some inconsistent greening at one
point
so the issue is i click there
that's showing me the function that is
applying to the thing that i
am currently in okay there we go yeah
this is much better i haven't really
noticed this we need to make sure and
again this is for
project management can we make sure that
in the new in 12
2 that we mentioned the screening change
uh yeah
yeah i can make sure that assuming that
i'm not confused about what the greeting
change is
my understanding that mostly change sort
of when you're
just outside with which guy is
selected right right it used to be
attached to the thing that's immediately
to your left and now it
searches higher is my under my
understanding of the change but
okay so but this is very useful what
this is doing here is very useful
because this is showing me what function
the thing if i were to type something
now like comma y
or something here that's showing me the
context in which that comma y
is i think this is the correct form of
greening that we should have had years
ago
and i've been confused i haven't even i
i've been greening blind
because i don't think it was doing the
right thing
um all right let's go back up here
so i think test applied is not
completely silly
and right well we need to
which default do we want i guess
uh i mean do we want it to have a one
arg form
well which which is exact exactly this
right
so in other words test applied of
of f would be the thing with the
non-junk
queue right
so so for what it's worth uh
in alpha they use corrupt q for what
what work we've been calling chunk q
that sounds a bit i think it's wrong
strong yes
do we like tests applied in this case
this is saying test applied so it's it's
so it's a test succeed additional
applied
i think it's test because it's a
function so the function is test
condition is an expression that's what i
was going to say
okay yeah right yeah just like pattern
test
right we yeah cases versus select
okay hold on test so this is does a test
and if the test is true it applies the
function
yep but if the test is not true it
propagates the
it applies the default function
right and then the question is is the
default function identity
or failure or something
well an interesting possibility is the
one argument form
could have the the um um
if you're saying the one and two
argument forms have different default
functions it's that's just going to
confuse people to no end
are you sure
and i think people will get tripped up
because they'll
you know start with the one arg form and
then they'll add a test
that's more specific to their use case
and yeah i i agree with brett
you know and the code above it is going
to be completely off you know caught
unawares or whatever
okay fair enough
we have a plug from nick on the live
stream here for
a oh yes
this is um for oh my gosh
wow
i gotta look at this this is this is
cool
right so this is the tensor notation
this is
an implementation of this bird track
notation stuff
we gotta understand whether you can make
whether you can
see because because the fact is in the
language
you know f of g of h of x
right very nice pipeline but if these
things have multiple arguments you're
toast
right if those have multiple arguments
threading the arguments through is a
really
real mess that's where
things like this could come in isn't
this also
what they call block language but it is
somewhat yes
but this is a notation
this is essentially a way i mean this is
look this is a long-running issue
is there a way to merge sort of
you know i had this idea years ago
of um uh
graph fix operators um
so the the notion would be just like you
have an infix operator like plus
right you could imagine a graph in which
you represent
something that is evaluable by having
essentially a graph where two things are
joined by an
edge which is essentially this graphical
notation
i mean block languages tend to represent
like in system modeler for example
they tend to represent things like
equations whereas
and and this is also not quite the same
thing i mean what i'm talking about is
the flow of data
through
i mean again there's a way to do this
there's a way
you see what i'm asking i mean here if f
and g
are two argument functions what do you
do right there's no at
sign composition for a two argument
function instead it's more something
where you are putting together
these wires to represent the flow of
data from one function to another
right
i mean i'm curious from people here do
you actually think this is useful i mean
if there was a nice
clean way to do multi-argument
composition would that be useful
christopher for example you're an
enthusiastic
at star and things like this yeah i mean
but the thing is is that
i i think i i don't think that there's
everyday use because it'll always be
more readable
and probably shorter just to write a
pure function
um and i can't
really think of an industrial use
yeah i mean this is this type of thing
that we're seeing here
is precisely where block languages
you know kind of like fail because they
do great
when you're going in a single line
yeah you see this is different this is
not doing the same thing this is
this is taking data and going
and moving that data to a different
place it's not
reinserting the data back in the same
computation
it's it's making a tap where something
happens
right
i mean that is an interesting thing is
is you know in a sense
well no the problem is okay so there's a
notion of what we might call
you know i'm getting this notebook is a
total mess but but
you know there's a notion of what we
might call data taps
um
and uh the
point with the data tap is where is it
going to put its output
right so that's what we're dealing with
here we've got
in in the main thing in our language is
that that there's one output
functions just have one output but if
you're
having all these data taps if you had a
bunch of dynamics running on the screen
then yes the data tabs have an end point
but if you're just trying to you know
sort of connect data together where do
they go
i mean i suppose that actually is an
interesting point
actually this is an interesting point
okay this gives me an idea
this is a so association mechanism
okay so here's the idea actually this is
interesting why have we not had this
idea before
or maybe this is trivial but but in
other words if you are going along
maybe all it is is just so of name
arrow x and then so of name arrow y
you know name two arrow y
and then basically a reap an association
of the reap
so is this not just yeah it's just
merge of reap of that part two comma one
comma identity yes
yes but the the concept is you are
from within a piece of code actually
this is an interesting idea
from within a piece of code you are
building up
outputs that you will then
you know you're spraying out outputs
that you will then collect in an
association to feed on to something else
in other words it's dealing with you
know how do you create
how do you quotes gradually create
you know multiple outputs for a function
now i mean which then you can i mean
this relates also to another thing which
we need to have a meeting about
which is port specifications which are
becoming a
a mess um can we add that to one of
these
these agendas is port specifications and
also talk about this notion of so
association for that
devin i think that will be for you yeah
okay let's come back to this
all right so we've got this notion of
test applied which we like quite a bit
um that means we need
this kind of replace thing which is
a i do i do still wonder though about
test applied and
and how much it adds over replace but
yeah we've already discussed that a
little bit
um replace
i mean this is what it is at the very
very beginning
you mean that you can implement it as
basically just replace
that is such a weird construct i mean so
what you're saying is
we would be saying something like
replace of
well blank slash semi you know blank
question mark failure queue
yeah replacement right yeah go go go go
sub def of
default goes to default applied to
expo yeah well just say replace it
expert comma that but yeah sure
well but this is the more direct form
that has
yeah well yeah why is that why is that
weird that
that is uh well used
i use such constructs all the time in my
code
i mean uh right because
the advantage especially uh sometimes in
place of a switch because the
problem with the switch is that you know
because it's not a rule but rather two
expressions you can't necessarily
use the parts of the uh
you know of the pattern in your
in the output of a switch but i use
expressions like this all the time to
well this is quite nice
and i have to admit i don't use this
much i have used it i worry about it a
little bit for various reasons but but
um
um i mean this does have the advantage
that you
get to do two things you get to test
because in test applied
i mean the the question is
um this is analogous to confirmed test
and i mean you could obviously imagine
but not desirably so
a match applied
in which you're giving essentially a
pattern
i mean what's interesting about match
applied is it's extremely close to the
pattern the structured version
of of function
which which i think we've we which is
another topic we need to discuss
it's somewhere on the agenda list
right but match applied is basically
what function would do
if it's given a pattern so match applied
here would say
if this thing matches this pattern
apply f otherwise do nothing
which is well that's not exactly what
function
would do right because presumably the
function would
would return completely unevaluated just
like if
no no no then values match
you were turned completely on yeah or or
an error which is what it does if you
give it the wrong argument structure i
mean if you give
right now if you give a function right
well if you if you give it too few
arguments
right if you give it this
right but you could give it four five
six and it won't complain
correct so this
is yeah it is a it is
on on some level a bit weird that
function doesn't just
you know uh reduce to
right that could reduce the function of
y four plus y
in some kind of closure type way right
but i i think partially i think we
discussed
that possibility a month or two ago not
as a main agenda item
but as you know that came up in the
process of discussing function
by the way this is this is this is i
mean in haskell this is used all the
time it's called partial evaluation
and it's really it it's much more useful
for them
because they basically use it for
operator forms because all of their
functions are designed like for example
they have a
take right but the argument order for
take
is take of number comma list but so that
means then that
the operator form all the operator forms
you just get for free by partial
evaluation
right but everything is current isn't it
yeah i mean but secretly like as in
the syntax is such that you don't
necessarily need to know that everything
is curried
i mean there it doesn't drop from the
right does but the arguments drop from
the right so
take take for just means is the
equivalent
of can work because it's dropping from
the right
yes right yeah you need to use the
syntax is weird
if that's what you mean like you have to
use these dollar signs or dots for
function composition to get the
precedence to be right
that's what you mean yeah okay the point
is that that take
take space 10 is the operator form that
takes the first 10 elements of the list
i see right by doing partial evaluation
so i mean we could do that for map for
example right if map didn't have an
operator form
yes yes
okay okay but anyway so what we've got
here the candidates here are test
applied
we don't yet know
um what does it mean when something
tests out okay
passes
verified
validated q verified q
i don't really like valid q but
when it tests you know it it is
tests out tests okay
q very bad um
it's accepted it's
an acceptable cue
but we want to resonate with the word
test if we're going to use test applied
um
and tested queue doesn't really make
sense
because that suggests it was externally
tested somewhere else
um
did you put verified in your list
i didn't but we've got so many other
things we've got verification
tests and so on i guess that's verified
queue
okay test applied says you do a test
and you test applied
is that name right go ahead maybe i
suggested this earlier but
what the for for the negative sense what
about spoiled cue
going for the fruit metaphor well
yes i suppose but right i mean there's
something that's going to spoil your
calculation
but that's not what spoiled q means
isn't it no it means this thing is
spoiled
but that doesn't mean that it will it is
the implication that because
one thing is spoiled it will spoil
everything else
i mean that's like contagious spoilage
right but but but but right this is the
thing that's uh
right this is the thing that's supposed
to be fail q or missing q
or or whatever right so
i mean in some sense that's spoiled
right you can't you can't do anything
with it
but you can i mean you can you can you
can do all sorts of things with them
right there
but you can't do what you what you want
to do with it
right the point of this is
right the point sure and you can you can
do something with your spoiled
bananas too right you can turn your
spoiled bananas into
a milkshake or something and redeem them
but you can't you can't make the fruit
salad you are going to make
yeah i i still would just yeah
i i still think that just failure cue
you know giving it time
yeah because i think that just the word
i think that first of all
adding another one it'll be unclear what
the difference is
and and then also it's just that once
there are three of them it's kind of
crazy
okay let me argue against this because
we're using failure as a propagating
error
you might need to detect whether you
have a propagating error
you mean an error what do you mean by
propagating error
an error that came from an enclosed
because enclosed by default generates
failure objects
so by that you mean okay so by that you
mean maybe
maybe there's some canonical format
that that so errors get wrapped in
well i mean isn't this something
that that maybe calls for for an
option right i mean if by default it
does you know catches everything but
there's an option to make it right
because on some sense
right i mean fairly your q right now
will also give true for dollar reported
which is not something that would ever
come from confirm or enclose
so if your standard is
well you could give it a second argument
which is a string which says what kind
of failures to allow
what does confirm do with that does
confirm did we ever figure that out did
it confirm does confirm have a second
argument that is types of errors
or was that no no no no no no i mean
confirm
by could be used to do something like
this but confirm has
you know has second argument has a third
argument and they do things
so yeah i see but there was there was
this that's why we have a
family of confirmed by confirm match i
think it's called
yes right confirmed by would be the
relevant one
right so confirmed by the default for
confirmed by
the default for confirm is that it is
confirmed by
of fa of x become a failure queue
right of this new failure queue you
failure queue so
so there's a missing thing which is what
what confirm
see i don't like that because of its
failure cue
enclose is propagating a failure
so it's a very well defined thing that
you want to test
is this a propagating failure that i see
before me well that that
that that that's head is failure queue
head equals failure queue i don't
understand why you would want to
distinguish these cases i mean
if you have an enclosed then you have
some way of dealing with
whatever popped out right
but you can just say confirm i mean this
is kind of a self-fulfilling thing you
could put a confirmer outside the
enclose
to essentially do the well but you
always need an enclosed around
your your confirm right so yeah
right so so you know if confirmed fires
it will throw you know modulo
crazy things you do or bugs and chris's
implementation
you know if confirm actually fires
because it detected a problem it will
throw a failure
and that failure will be caught by a
confer
by an enclosed excuse me and
you know at that point right if you
really want to
know of course you know
at that and at that point all you know
is that what returned was a failure
object you don't know whether this was
a failure object that was thrown by
confirm or just
the expression evaluated to yeah you
know
all right so what we're proposing is
failure q is extended
to deal with missings and indeterminants
or not and then potentially it has a
second argument which is a string
that is the type of failure it should be
considering
sure and i mean i'm sure what we could
have a whole family
of such strings for abject
abject failure i see
it took me a second
yes uh maybe not that one although
you know we right i mean look this is
the question of
how critical is the error this is what
we discussed for confirm
is the possibility of a string name that
means things like
you know for example if if
if certain functions are fed something
symbolic and come back symbolically
it's a sign that they weren't very badly
wrong other functions that's not the
case with
um right this is the fundamental problem
about
there are many different ways that
functions can
signal that they have not worked right
and i think that the the point the point
here though
is just that it's just that there's a
there are a few
common ways like returning dollar failed
failure object dollar aborted
dollar canceled etc missing
that that are like kind of the standard
modern ways to do it right well i mean i
don't necessarily agree that dollar can
sold is an error right that means the
user decided to dismiss
the dialogue without changing anything
which may or may not be
well it means that you didn't get a
value that's why it's that's why it's
likely to be a failure
but but you're right like many of these
things
one person's failure is somebody else's
success
right in fact i get very annoyed when
dialogues don't have a cancelled button
so i can
zero out whatever stupid change i
accidentally made
right okay but i mean so so what we're
suggesting here there's a family
of string arguments to failure cue which
define various kinds of failure
conditions this is exactly
analogous it's a slightly cleaner
version of what we were proposing to do
for confirm
right what went wrong what kind of a
thing went wrong what kind of a thing do
you have
you know in other words that there is a
potential
you know there's a potential somewhat
heuristic thing which is
this is a meaningful meaningless pile of
symbolic gunk
that could never mean anything to
anybody
but of course it might mean something to
somebody i mean you know you can
this is this is why this is an undoable
thing it's the same reason
i mean this is why we have discussed a
calculus of errors
right so in other words we're we're
we're constructing a thing that
represents something going wrong
okay most of the time our language is
just producing results
okay let's wax philosophical for a
second
that there are you know the primary
purpose of what we're computing right
now is to get results
to get output there are two things we
might want
one is a trace of how you got that
output that's another structure that you
could imagine
having and another is things like
you know something went wrong
what went wrong and you know
what we have emphasized is before the
confirming closed world
the only thing we were doing in the what
went wrong category was generating
messages for humans
confirming close begins to make that
more computable
but in general we could imagine a
a sort of a comment structure that says
what what do you think of the thing you
just got is it really likely to be the
right thing
or is this something that isn't you know
if you know if for example let's take
the anglo-spanish war
if the anglo-spanish war was in it was a
variable and a polynomial it almost
certainly wouldn't be the right thing
did this make any sense i mean i you
know i can clearly say yeah
sure sure sure although just because
it's an
entity because i'm sure there are
there's code all over the place that
uses
you know entities as i mean that is
almost certainly meaningless
right yeah yeah right i mean look
at some level i mean that example is
something that other languages would
have like a type system or something
like that but i mean this is the point
look this is sort of the point with the
confirmed things is that basically
you you know somewhere you need to tell
it because that might be meaningful
there's nothing
structural about that that makes it
meaningless the thing that's meaningless
is just to you
as a programmer this is meaningless and
so the point is you just need to specify
you know this is what i expect this to
be right exactly but that's
and that and that's why you have
confirmed by you you say exactly
what are the allowed things right right
and what what the advantage of confirm
buy and confirm match they are
more powerful version of something like
the constriction associated with the
type system
the only the only thing they're not
doing is
automatically applying themselves at
every step i mean one could imagine
a uh
they're like type like type annotations
but where
yeah yeah yes but they're not they're
not
what we used to call in version 0.9 uh
rodentifying functions functions what
no i i just uh is is that oh
is that what we more commonly call
burrowing functions
or yes yes the functions that burrow
into things
like for example map all burrows
deep into anything right as opposed to
so the question would be a rodentifying
form of confirm
well this is exactly what we're talking
about
much earlier about the the sort of um
what was it
generalized here because replace failure
because
because delete missing does this but in
a more useful way
because just blatant or identification
you can do with like map all and stuff
like that
but but the point is is that something
like um delete missing
lets you give the two level specs and
that's like critical for its usefulness
right so so what you're proposing before
before we go down this
road too much because uh the meeting has
already gone significantly over time and
i
i want to make sure we're all in
agreement in in what we have actually
agreed upon
so junk is just going to be failure
queue
yes so this is going to replace
failure which i like i think that's a
fairly
that's a that's a pretty easy to
understand name
yep if you see what so this what this
will look like
is you know let's say this would be a
typical thing replace
failure null list expert
well what is this i was just imagining
that this has the exact same syntax as
replaced missing
well this is a this is a um
this is an operator form it's an
operative form but there isn't a
replacement thing
i'm sorry delete missing delete missing
but i guess you need to give it a thing
to replace with
yes in this case okay fine
right so replace failure does this um
i think it should also have a
non-operator form then that's analogous
to deletion oh i agree
i agree replace failure computation
comma
blah and then it could potentially have
a lev spec
level spec two level specs
right n
which is one and d which is one
okay and then
are we happy with tests applied
or or is that still on the i think test
applied is okay i i'm okay with it i
think we should try
implementing that i think that makes
makes with
what default third argument
i think identity
but then this case is ugly well i mean
but so so that case
you get nested failures as the result
right so if you put this in the third
argument three argument case
it's also meaningless like failure can't
just be given a single thing
argument like that right so i mean like
he hears the thing right so
confirm it's not totally trivial like
for example what confirm does
is it will it basically checks it has
some
some somewhat dumb heuristics where it
checks to see if the failure object
was thrown by another confirm in which
case it just you know
regurgitates it verbatim otherwise it
will wrap it in a failure object
right so maybe maybe we should have a
function that kind of does that that
canonicalizes things into failure
objects
but it seems like that's not super
necessary because
if we have a function right if we have
some function like failure q that
detects failures
then anything that failure recruit if
anything that failure q returns true on
you don't really need to wrap it in a
failure object because you can already
sort of
easily detect it's a failure if that
makes sense but the only reason to wrap
something in a failure
failure object is if it's sort of
non-obviously a failure and some other
function might not realize it's a
failure
what about the possibility that failure
if you give it an arbitrary experience
this is probably wrong given an
arbitrary expression will canonicalize
it to what that why
i think that's that's kind of crazy okay
fine um yeah i mean
we could add a you know an automatic
as the function which is interpreted as
do whatever canonicalization
that uh automatic for what as the third
argument for test applied
i think that's an interesting idea so so
then then okay so hold on a second so
that would be
test applied by the way i don't think we
want to completely forget match applied
but but
but let's so test applied f
and then our condition here
test
no what's the test i mean the test is
okay an automatic means
okay then automatic there means wrap
okay so that's the alternative to
identity wrap it in a failure object
wrap it appropriately in a failure
object it's a little weird that the
automatic is not the default
what would hap what would it mean if the
if failure was that third argument
or you're saying that you would expect i
mean but you could imagine
that doing something automatic there
automatically doing the appropriate
rapping
in that case well
i mean i think that's kind of ugly i
mean i'm okay with it
with automatic there but now you're
using failure
uh you know not as the function to be
applied but yeah
sort of magical thing yeah it's crazy if
we're gonna do that it should be a
string
right but but i think automatic is is
sort of
the right thing to do here and you know
then as opposed to identity being the
default case
so there's a case where automatic is not
the default
uh yeah that that's my initial
inclination
yeah all right we should try it okay by
the way borrowing confirm
it's not a serious name but but what
that would be is
take an expression and basically
evaluate it so that every piece of its
evaluation
has a confirm wrapped around it actually
it will be rather
is this completely crazy i think it's
kind of insane i mean i did actually see
something i figured out where i saw
something on the community or something
where someone said that
that they'd like to have some way of
evaluating things
such that you know if a failure or a
dollar fail or anything like that ever
comes up then it stops
but i think this is kind of insane
because
you know like if you did something like
oh
is you know f of x like if you said if f
of x equals
dollar failed then do this then that
will immediately fail everywhere because
yes right yeah right so there's crazy
stuff like that
but i know i mean this is i'm telling
you this is the calculus of errors which
is a
very very messy thing just like the
calculus of provenance of computational
results is very messy
although not to to the combinator horn
again
i think i may have figured out something
that is a way of using these causal
graphs we have
to give a fairly general notion of
provenance
for what it's worth i mean it's
basically the causal graph that shows
what part of what depended on what's to
get the results you get to
um for what it's worth and by the way i
finally think trace
i may finally have a way to to
resuscitate trace
and make trace actually produce
something useful
as a as a graph object basically
i can see everybody is really
enthusiastic about that uh well i think
to be perfectly honest i'm a little
tired after this
meeting has now run double its scheduled
length okay all right okay well we
should wrap it up
um because it doubles not that bad
that's true but but
you know when this meeting started i
still had natural sunlight and now i'm
sitting in darkness
and that's not you know that's not
healthy but
um okay they
well i know we have another yeah we're
not going to get to this
right we'll just save these two for for
the next meeting in two weeks it's
it's no big deal neither of these items
is time critical so
although i want to know what's wrong
with imported object before just so
oh just the name rubs me the wrong way
um i mean you can look at my couple of
bullet points i
just sort of want to understand uh
what we really think we're doing with
this and can we come up with a better
name
that's okay and basically what it is
is it's something from the outside world
that will be fed back out to the outside
world
but it's primarily intended it is a
handle to a thing in the outside world
we've already had this issue
with external function for example
that it is a handle out to something in
the outside world
not directly meaningful to us but useful
to re-feed out to the outside world
right and and what we're doing here
i forget where this first came up sean i
think if he's still here
it was it was the pem oh man gosh that
horrifying thing yes right
there but but in general it's a thing
just to say it
in general it's a thing where we are
importing data from some format
and there is a piece let's say we're
importing some cad format
let's say we're importing some standard
which isn't really a standard
but you know it's a cad format where
there's supposedly a standard but
actually this particular implementation
also supports you know quintix surfaces
or something
and the question is how do we represent
the quintex surface when it comes in
uh i'm not sure that that that is that
what you just said there is consistent
with the rough page as it is currently
written
so let's let's let's you know like i
said
it's not critical uh it's not critical
we're not going to change anything for
12
2. it's marked experimental so we can
you know fix it in in the next version
so we'll uh we'll deal with it when we
have
time and energy okay all right fine but
but did that
did my explanation at least make sense
almost okay all right fine
okay um all right uh we uh
oh that did go very over time oh well
well go ahead yeah now i
i was just gonna say good evening okay
all right thanks everybody and thanks to
folks on the live stream
and we'll see you again another time